les images de las vegas ce matin très
tôt vous le voyez crise et à la taille
nous a parlé de ce panneau géant qui est
installé on va on va te manquer mon ami
qu'on peut lire gregory charles on est
très contents de l'accueillir qui a
évidemment très bien connu rené angélil
et céline dion vous avez tourné avec 1,2
en plus de 80 spectacles mais vous
l'avez connu iolotan à 8 nuls
l'anecdote moi j'étais en train
d'acheter un projet qui à l'époque pour
nous extrêmement important avec radio
canada il ya longtemps l'auteur on parle
de débuter et 80 j'avais 12 ans et on
était dans un grand studio à longueuil
entraînant racheter ce projet à l'autre
bout du corridor dans un minuscule
studio il y avait un rallye qui
enregistrent les premières chansons de
céline et au moment de la pause
l'algérie dans notre dans nos studios
j'aurai besoin de quelqu'un pour faire
des back vocals pour une chanteuse et
nous prouver le projet tellement gros
qu'on pensait que c'est de la générosité
de les chanter pour l'autre notre projet
disparu de la map
mais elle a vraiment bien marché et ce
phénoménal c'est que après c'est
vraiment le cd le projet de sa vie mais
après ce qu'il m'avait entendre juste
une fois de toujours été intéressé est
ce que je faisais à chaque fois que je
le croisais rencontrés sur des plateaux
télé ou des bruins un site autre info ce
post d'affaires loyers
c'était pas n'était pas de la flume
c'est vous l'avez dit hier et récemment
beaucoup de boutiques il s'intéressait
vraiment aux gens qui parlaient il ya
des grosses vedettes qui parlent que
d'eux c'était le contraire dans son cas
il vous en appliquant votre mère est
tombée malade
il est à l'hopital moi je suis tombé de
scène une dizaine d'années j'ai ouvert
les yeux après d'anastasie qui étaient
là rené angélil et puis la face et qu'il
y en a aussi des gens qui s'intéressent
à vous parce que il ya quelques choses
peuvent aller julie
mais se pose c'est pas juste bien après
être allé chercher avons réussi à
motiver tout le monde a donné son 250 %
pour ces dames parce que si ce qu'il
réussisse à faire tout ce qui entre avec
ces deux là ont fait ça parce que
c'était un terrain extraordinaire qui a
été membre puis on l'est on le faisait
aussi parce que lui le coach de hockey
il faisait comprendre que même si tu
étais sur le quatrième trio que tu
pouvais contribuer au succès de son
projet puis on l'a tous fait et on le
fait encore volontairement pour eux
tout le monde était important tous les
musiciens dans quelle mesure pour l'à
beaucoup souligné hier mais il était de
tous les détails
moi ce qui m'impressionne c'est que en
général les gens qui sont dans le détail
qui sont remises plus sont aussi très
agressé un cri fatigué le lycée doit
plus cool que j'ai rencontré dans ma vie
cool puis pas juste parce qu'il y avait
des be cool drôme cool intéresser à ce
qui se passe ça intéresse à faire des
farces intéressés à prendre un verre
intéresse à jo quatre étaient toujours
aller au restaurant un bon vivant un
hippie curie couilles mais dans
l'arrière de sa tête a roulé tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps
toujours entrain poser de question
turque
si je voulais faire ce qu'est ce t'en
penses y était toujours en train de
collecter de l'information des autres et
encore une fois c'est une marque ecstasy
dans le grec est au sommet de la
pyramide
mais quand même intéressé à ce que tout
le monde avait à dire autour et comment
il pouvait abonder d une dialectique qui
suis là à essayer d obtenir parce que
son but c'était que son projet céline
réussissent et gens vivent système passé
pour lui de faire rire des autres il le
faisait aussi parce que vous avez dit
hun sen lui nos rêves aura été plus
petit ils attendent avez vous pouvez
vous et vous comprenez bien ce que ça
veut dire vous exportez des spectacles
lui il n'y avait pas de les mettre là il
n'y avait pas de limites et il ne devait
surtout pas y en avoir le nombre de fois
que j'ai entendu dans les meetings et on
réglera ce qu'il passe après c'était il
n'y avait jamais de limites
admettre et alors quand on le côtoie
liés on finissait par passer la même
chose pour nous mais c'est sûr qu'il y
était inspirée par une chanteuse qui en
a pas de limite céline c'est une grande
voix mais ceci n'est pas où je peux
faire n'importe quoi avec ça ça aide
mais il le pensait pour les autres aussi
moi je pense que dalle succès de céline
évidemment mais dans le succès de vie
rené guy cadou arcade fire ii du cirque
du soleil le cirque ils proposent en
règle ils sont puissants par le maître
mais je pense qu'il ya dans le succès de
toutes ces entités là est certainement
dans le nôtre aussi limité soit il est
beaucoup de ce run et avec les pieds sur
terre mais avec les mains tendues vers
les étoiles nous disait que tout est
possible
je vous ai entendu
gregory charles à franck nous envoie la
radio dire que vous avez été vous
l'objet de d'épisodes raciste en tout
cas au japon notamment pendant cette
tournée leur raconter lui que lui
oulalala il réagit à tout ce qui est
évidemment là c'est très personnel mais
c'est moi je laime encore plus l'année
parce que il aurait eu des raisons de
juste vouloir étouffer des choses mais
effectivement en asie il ya un certain
racisme je dirais ce général pas juste
pour les noix pour une toux ceux qui
sont pas dans tout le japon sur
jean-paul japonais l'ayguade jeunes
messins étaient des musulmans pendant
cette tournée locke ou plaisir et puis
plein sur l'avion on obtient plus de
place dans votre bureau et ça tombait
toujours sur moi et à chaque occasion
rené intervenait lui même était prêt à
aller jusqu'aux autorités suprêmes posé
ce qui se passe pour nous ça va se
passer pour lui sinon nous allons avoir
affaire à moi et on est sans 440 à pour
monter dans l'avion
est ce arrivé en asie star iv ou saison
était sur un terrain de golf avec plein
show biz et il y avait plein dread hill
en plus en amont c'est interdit l'accès
internet on lui a fait comprendre
il ya des régions états unis où ça
arrivera cas aurait fait comprendre que
tout re prépare sûrement le fun d'avoir
un go basané sur son derrière et sa
réaction était et les résoudre que je
mentionne c'est pas parce que ça me
donne pas plus d'importance c'est que
oui la volonté de réussir oui le succès
oui la ténacité mais devançant y avait
la fraternité la fidélité les valeurs
humaines et jeu tout le monde la même
chose pire le tous vécu dans notre for
intérieur de façon très personnelle il à
un quelconque moment dans la vie de tout
chez moi je connais qui ont travaillé
avec lui il a mis de côté son intérêt
personnel ou l'avancement facile pour
l'amitié puis les valeurs humaines et
c'est pour ce qu'est aujourd'hui
en fait on est tous plaît à répéter la
même chose c'est un grand homme
oui ingrate après sérieux un grand coach
un grand artiste aussi mais c'est un
grand homme surtout comparé d'une
extrême sensibilité chez pas vous avez
revu cette entrevue qui le donnait à
stéphane bureaux et redit le diffusé
hier bien la fin dit oui nous sommes au
sommet mais les valeurs importantes
c'est mes enfants c'est ma famille on ne
pourra pas continuer à ce rythme là je
sens que je m'appelle
un peu de mon arme de ce qui est
important de mes valeurs
c'était beaucoup sur moi je pense que
vraiment toujours eu peur de se perdre
et peut-être que pour cette raison là il
en mettait encore plus d'être bien
ancrés sur terre d'être à l'écouté en
contact id est généreux je pense que
c'est une personne généreuse de nature
mais je pense qu'elle n'a n'y a pas plus
parce qu'elle est pour qu'il se perde
fallait surtout pas que sedin ce pas
chapelle ardente jeudi église notre dame
vendredi les funérailles
ça va être un moment assez intense je
passerai des moments intenses moi
personnellement je vis tout ça comme une
célébration
d'abord parce qu'il a souffert beaucoup
à la fin plus que jamais voir les gens
qu'on a un parti mais c'est aussi une
femme que ça dure pas éternellement
cette souffrance mais moi je pensais
vraiment de ses libérations
son succès c'est l'autre succès perdure
il envoyait il savait que son succès
c'est le québec au complet qui avec
raison et j'ai envie de dire inversement
sa brillance sa nature humaine
extraordinaire c'est aussi nous il ya de
quoi célébrer en tout cas il vous a
touchée par est moins profondément en
plus d'en avoir donné un paquet de trucs
mais moi j'étais assis à côté lui dans
le train dans l'avion l'un disait moi
j'ai pas réussi à ce point là mais
quasiment tous les jours je rate al je
vais être le chef
comme ça qu'on l'appelait orientale chef
nous et sauf mais toujours dans la
générosité de léguer richard ce plaisir
merci merci par la prochaine